you posted a picture of Thanos getting
ready for this premiere first I'm not in
charge of that I don't know they do I
don't know why they're post I don't know
who's writing that stuff now come on
they put a big naked annals out there me
it's a hundred percent made Instagram
does your does your behind look like the
a noses like that I mean I sure like to
think so as a 51 year old guy to think
that it's hiked up like that rounded
beautifully with a sheen on it I would
like to think so
don't put it on the carpet right now hey
this is called endgame but we're asking
everybody blink once if you live blink
twice if you die stare and then I get a
blank and then I don't know what you
said I don't remember cuz I'm nervous no
you're not telling me a damn thing
there's nothing to tell you you're
asking ghosts we don't exist right now
we will exist after the movie will have
all kinds of answers but right now it's
like all up in the air I mean I think I
know what happens but I thought I knew
what happened in infinity war and when I
saw it I was like okay so I was totally
wrong no so I'm like I'm literally a fan
seeing this movie I have no idea what's
going to happen I'm excited three hours
that's gonna be pretty good hours and 56
seconds it's good
you